and Coco it's Monday it's dreamy its
Coco II Beth Morosky here in the chat
room Jason I'm Alec Cooper the corner
there we go my boy today we're playing a
game
I'm very excited about it's called ABS
you I think that's how you say it
yes yeah tell us if we're abs you ABS up
what is the carrot thank God the you is
there because otherwise you just be
called ABS yeah which is fine I'm
working on mine we're all working on
them all right good to see you guys calm
throughout Adel 2013 I love this music
by the way it's still like oh yeah
that's what we've been having to in the
background people are like the alien
Overlord that's right exactly
ABS you now this game I've heard I know
we played a game called journey on here
which was we were a guy with a with a
scar for the desert walking around I've
heard this is kind of scrub his journey
under water whoo here we go here's the
thing now I will say this the ocean is a
beautiful place but it's terrifying
yes oh my God look how deep were going
we're really fish you know one thing
they didn't put in here is the massive
amounts of plastic that's floating
around yeah oh we're down at the
jellyfish level further
okay now I'm actually getting a little
freaked out it's very low
whoa it is
um this is cool yeah weird up a Slayer
Darth what's up whoa
oh wait now we're back on top can I move
around nope
alright we're a dead divert well though
this is all saw the Jason Bourne movie
starts yeah over Jason Bourne whoo all
right this game is very pretty I love
these games like cel-shading all right
let's see what okay we can look around
here
oh we pronounced it right we did
absolute I pronounce a six different
ways so what does that mean right I
really mostly be said Abzu press to dive
press what to dive up there we go now
wait I can't swim is this gonna be a
problem
leave this let's go down old to swim can
I just hold my breath forever you know
one thing I hate about video games is
you never get to go that long underwater
you know and like all these games like
we're playing no man's sky
we're playing other games you only get
like you're you're at your oxygen boost
is like your oxygen levels like this
it's in this game I feel like we can go
underwater quite a bit we let's boost
move boost
Wow this is cool
go find it Titanic oh good one this is
like that other game somebody say yes
well played very articulate I can do
flips pretty easy what can I do what
else can I do yes you're on ps4 look how
graceful I am there's this great Kurt
Vonnegut quote where he's like in the
water I'm beautiful that's right oh look
at this dude we can breakdance yeah yeah
boy
check this out fishy Oh
oh you know what when I hit that I hit a
button and like Aquaman all the fish
come over to me I sound sick I was at a
wedding in Seattle where I screamed the
entire time why are we screaming period
and yes
dancer question it was people in real
life how long held my breath underwater
I don't know should we try to we have a
contest where you hold our breath right
now okay already I would in the chat
hold their breath okay ready one two
three
[Music]
so gun this is the best show now welcome
we want to talk about the Westway how
does it from this mug
what I'm saying that's true we get a
rider
blue-eyed monster Team Coco forever
correct
what if what if you pass out and can't
finish the stream
[Music]
he's still going guys
and how wasn't he dead that's all I got
it's pretty good how long was that we
weren't even timing it's [ __ ] wasn't
us 82 lying this game he's dumped a deal
to an odd 213 well I'm a little hurt
I can't go up top anymore guys we can't
I feel a little claustrophobic I'm
wondering what the point of this game is
this is cool it's very pretty
you know this game games like this keeps
like flour a journey music and sound are
so important and so far the music and
sound is dope it does feel lush guys you
know they say we know more about outer
space that we do our own planet on the
bottom of the ocean whoo here we go now
we're talking
yeah whoa
turtle Holograms wait am i releasing
turtles this is a turtle release game
yeah turtle release
[Music]
let's go down
[Music]
go deeper deeper
candy corn plants release the tortes
this is cool I wonder how much I wonder
how much research was done making this
game because that'd be pretty cool
that's a good thing to tell your
employer like hey I gotta go out scuba
diving oh yeah yeah yeah
gotta go scuba diving for research oh
people are asking what your shirt says
today my shirt says I know guacamole is
extra and if you've ever eaten Chipotle
you know what I'm talking about they
always ask you and everyone knows
guacamole is extra everyone knows
O'Mally what card what do you mean free
chips and guac wait a second to get out
of here I think I need to release
something but I released some turtles
this is cool look at this think of these
ankles this is already better than no
man's sky by the way oh wait here we go
I gotta release these things I will see
you know it's kind of annoying yeah I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do it now I'm this
guy this guy
just I used to be an invert guy ah now
I'm screwed myself up you need to find a
robot in the land you know what
found it
here's a question are we even on earth
you know what but you guys didn't think
about that
what is abs you mean well yeah what does
it mean I got a little robot buddy
[Music]
wait
[Music]
Brussels Belgium is here yeah Brussels
Belgium is my people where it is uh can
we get a little info about this game in
the stream like what the goal is I'm not
yeah I'm not quite sure we're figuring
it out
hey the goal is to have fun guys isn't
that the goal of every game just grow up
to discover ancient secrets lie
forgotten encounters
good job creatures await probably
probably to something like that suppose
like you're reading something there's a
shark now there are things guys I hate
to burst everyone's bubble here there
are things the ocean that are not our
friends okay not everything is all
hunky-dory in the ocean oh and this
looks like a dangerous thing also we
don't even know for on earth it could be
we could be in the heart of Abzu which
is the most evil planet in the galaxy
you know are those eels or those eels
freaked me out by the way so absolute
means deep water is that correct
ooh absolute means deep water well
athlete arts is that correct
is a lush and beautiful environment I
feel graceful yeah last week were you go
dancing yeah this is great although now
the music is getting a little freaky
let me do it look at this maybe this
will move damn it I screwed up my stupid
pitch think I should turn it back boost
oh this looks dangerous is that a
spaceship yeah ice cream I'm going back
to the inverted pitch I can't
I'm nervous
you know what you ever see that movie at
open water like a movies freaky the
people get left on the scuba thing and
then they basically just die and spoiler
alert what do you say spoiler before
after you spoil something are you sure
it's not like hey alert I just spoiled
something look it's like the end of edge
of tomorrow whoa
this is cool guys it looks just like my
apartment oh wait hey sweet digs sweet
digs whoa we're in some kind of crazy
Cathedral hey what's that little this
guy a Jew is a mythological underworld
ocean of pure water in Mesopotamians
every standard mythology Oh
so we're basically it no wait there's
another Lake what ocean and ocean wait
do we got oceans on oceans on oceans
what is good wait we're under the water
under the water whoa wait I'm like
upside down or something
[Music]
this I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
freaked out about this freezy it's like
an interesting like what is up down yeah
what is up what's down
it looks like my mansion and yeah yeah
exactly or my shitty one-bedroom
apartment
it has crickets okay name references a
constant from the oldest pathologies
combinations of words
AB meaning ocean and Zahm you need to
know math me know AB from sweet ABS bro
yes and ocean from Billy ocean yeah but
yeah you're right I think this person is
wrong so this is this game is basically
about Billy ocean's ABS what's happening
here this is crazy cool whoa look at
this wait now this is like underwater
Inception look we're outside this crazy
thing
wait are we outside in space we're
underwater this is awesome
you guys I want to live in this game I
hate my life and hate Los Angeles I love
this game this game is the opposite of
Los Angeles there's water everywhere
it's really calming all the fish are
cool so far you know a couple of fish
would date me you know it's totally
different velocities we're going into
this nexus portal here doing a boost
when in doubt fly at policy I knew it
oops that missed out didn't use my sweet
what's this we're touching a big blob of
jelly my god what's happening
I just took a globe out of my chest
and made an underwater tree released a
bunch of stingrays
guys awesome whoa oh look oh I see it
was all it was all dead and stuff before
but now I made water weather I mean
there was already water and I need more
water life
that means water zooming zoom means far
Mesopotamians believe many rivers
sources lakes in spring forth from ABS
you the underwater ocean oh I see as the
source of all water
I love the twitch chat says that the
YouTube chat says what's up with the
echo the dolphin sonar I don't know
that's how we interact with things bill
singleton
this is awesome my god which we pop up
to the surface real quick and see what's
going on
[Music]
I'm popping around you know what I don't
see any land what if we get tired what
are we gonna eat hey what's that up
there wait a second it's that way up
there it's that way up there oh yeah
that blue
[Music]
I want to go to there
it's dope alright we're going deep
what's that thing that happens if you go
too deep and then you come back up and
you get stuff in your blood oh yeah an
album hey shady the objective in this
game so far is to I think like promote
life you'd like find these little things
these little checkpoints that you
interact with and then things spring to
life everything becomes very beautiful
this music is awesome
California wet again yeah make her wet
again and by her I mean California here
my other cover wait a second wait we've
got some mythology guys back it up back
it up
mythology alert alright let's look at
this so let's see at one point there
were people there carrying the Tree of
Life right this can also be a Kanye
video oh yeah also possible yeah there's
a record of a Kanye video from thousands
of years ago
alright and we got pots and stuff
so this is our karin some kind of leaves
and all that stuff cool I got myself he
came with me oh wait a second there's
something over here we got fish and
wheat and
there's a lot of cool jellyfish you know
what time I went swimming in the Red Sea
Sharm el-sheikh I went down scuba dive
scuba diving but what do they call it
snorkeling went down and at one point in
the day I didn't realize this all the
jellyfish come to the surface all these
tiny little jellyfish they're probably
each one was like this big not stinging
jellyfish but I didn't know this
differently so we're out there a lot of
jellyfish and I come up and it's just
the waters covered in jellyfish and so I
was like swimming through jellyfish
they're all like like in my ears and
stuff it was like that's very creepy
they're very cool guys I had my own Abzu
experience what I'm trying to say this
is death they made a game based on my
experience so basically all right
there's kelp there's fish maybe the
different levels then there's robed
creatures though there's a giant whale
then there's some kind of a city then
there's the Sun and then we beat in the
game right I'm changing the I'm changing
the pitch back I can't deal with this
all right here we go that's true Slayer
dad says at least I'm not swimming in
Michigan water I would be poisoned ah
this is true I will say Lake Erie is one
of the Great Lakes
one of the large I think the only body
of water to ever catch fire it was so
polluted
Ohio's River although he's a river of
body water I ask you oh Jesus Christ
wait why does that jerk have explosive
no it better camera oh oh dude no photo
no photos he had no funds Oh see this is
what scares me about the ocean this
right here yeah like an emo we're going
down let's see how far down we can go
dude oh my god I'm actually freaked out
right now
this is the bottom
it's the bottom holy [ __ ] wait this is
crazy look at this
I didn't think you'd be able to go down
this is awesome I'm really kind of
afraid bothersome battery can release
something to fight can these guys fight
the shark white sharks are dicks that's
true
lake uri geller I'm not sure you're
talking about review by Nature
whoa this is awesome they've made
they've done a good job at making like
making you feel like you're starting
something a part of something very epic
yeah that was like that game inside that
I loved it was like you felt like you're
part of something huge well what's this
where are the Sharks of the lasers yeah
dude
we're about to see him I feel extremely
small and helpless and that way a little
freaked out I also like how you can't
see that far yeah and you're not like
controlling like what angle were looking
at right now
you notice how the happy music one way
oh yeah yeah I feel a little disturbed
I'm a little freaked out you guys I'm
not gonna lie to you I'm the ocean it
deserves our respect y'all I could you
make the could you push the twitchchat a
little over the left so I can see it as
a human race need to be more concerned
about the waters and oceans I agree
Lamia
I hope they can't be are working with
games like this yeah oh my god this game
very insane well you guys tell you what
together oh yeah good one cubed Jane
Jane you know I read both chats I just
want you guys to know that yeah some
should be nice some have more
interesting content then yeah what's
this find a giant thing now wait a
second the other one we could interact
with this one we keep oh we already did
interact with this one hey there's a
little Lobster hey buddy you don't need
to think about it lobsters like such
like a delicacy but it's basically just
a water spider yeah it's in there the
crab
they're just big waters but if they
lived I guess crabs do live on that on
the earth on land they wouldn't be
nearly as electable all right let's go
up I think we're supposed to go up um
this is scaring me being this deep
that's what she said about playing ABS
you
is where the turtles came from yeah
you're right gracias not sure VR would
suit this spend a lot of time trying to
certain shades of blue well I think
maybe this is cool though but dude you
can't say that looking at this the first
person wouldn't be amazing all these
fish swimming around you that would be
dope hey Beth wanna see a trick the fish
like ten points the fish be feeling me
let's go up here and see what's up
let's go for this horrifying giant robot
vagina yep that's what this is right oh
my god whoa where are we going dude I'm
boosting through this this scares me
Aaron's voice sounds Herman today he's a
little ill a little ill guys um I went
to a wedding in Seattle it's very fun
had a good time I was exhausted when I
left for Seattle and even more tired
when I got back I slept like the dead
last night of course I had to watch big
brother of course I had to catch her
from above all your fish are belong to
us what's up the game doesn't freeze
here as that would be different loaning
happening well while we load I'll talk a
little bit about my experiences in the
ocean okay see oh okay
I was gonna tell you guys about the
summer to nude beach but yeah with my
parents oh oh look at this
oh we got a current we got a current
situation whoa whoa something's
happening
can I rock are these fish a ride with me
dude it's awesome let's get into these
fish come back fish yeah fish yeah this
is awesome this is great I hope so
hey if you guys are feeling a little sad
or depressed all you got to do is play
Abzu this game is dope this is this
makes you happy it's a fun game all
right let's hear
I love it this music I think this is
like Christmas music kind of like I
think it's too good now something better
oh yeah I feel like we're about me
saying a lot about yeah oh we missed
those guys I want to hit that I gotta
hit more red stuff there's so many fish
is this that is this that many is this
as many fish that are in the sea that's
not a question
Spanish fish look Ellie's fish there is
no way we are not gonna get killed in a
second but maybe you can't even die in
this game after he's not about death
look at this whoa oops sorry I just flew
through jellyfish you know it's a lot
this ocean is a lot less scary when
you've got all your pals of you
I'm doing a couple somersaults just do
down case there's like skill points
[Music]
how many absolutely jokes have there
been no zero there's been zero your
first Wow who made the first absolutely
joke well done I'm a little sick so I'm
off my absolutely game hey man can you
expand that twitch at its what did Danny
open didn't do this but it's awesome I
love damage
hey let's ride one of these big fish bro
come back I want to ride you oh yeah you
can get like the album really can I ride
this dude I maybe I can ride one of
these dolphins this game is awesome it's
like being in a painting this is like
the prisoner filter alright let's go
down and try that way I'm gonna ride one
you gonna ride one of these dolphins can
I ride a dolphin
did you think about how some dolphins
and oh I forgot where Hawaii pufferfish
they're trying to like they don't get
any rest because people are always
trying to swim with them
cuz if they sleep with their eyes open
people don't know and so they're really
sleepy on like beaches in Hawaii you
can't just lock them away so they can
get their wrist oh that's awesome guys
let me ride you come here come on bro
come on let me ride you bro yeah look
I'm riding him this is awesome
Aaron's being a bit absent-minded with
the punish soccer man I got an idea
let's put on what goggles on Al in this
world 24/7 I agree
just chilling back to school school of
fish right thank you trying to raise my
game alright let's go down here let's go
to this weird oh wait the dark holes
where we came out of what is the best
beach in California I need to find
another camera with the Sharky my camera
let's go around and use our sonic 'no
soup nope whoa press the touchpad to
meditate oh yeah never like now you are
well rested
please Bethan meditating who's re excuse
me I'll let you be guys I think we could
all use a little meditation on this
Monday morning
ooh look wait when you meditate you can
fly around cool this is so weird press
the touchpad button to stop meditating
oh my god whoa oh you can oh you switch
between groups of fish
wow this is a great OC look it shows us
oh it's showing us the names of the fish
blue surgeon fish oh it's this one is it
screensaver mode reef trigger fish yeah
this is doh
I just want to be in this game banner
fish
well banner fish is making its way all
right enough meditator
how am i breathing underwater fizz all
right we gotta find a camera's what we
have to do what are my camera pals so
gonna search around here camera nope oh
no did I just release more sharks no it
tells you what you released in the
corner
isn't easy to do what are you guys
heading to New York City Dober 31st you
heard here Bert oh no wait it's hard we
did not look at these guys I go by and
they'll say hello what is the age rate
is it educational that's the question
this I don't know but this feels kind of
education bunch of naked fish yeah
humping each other I should look up more
over here it's easy for everyone e for
everyone for everyone
abso have you guys ever a taquito
watching the war there's what we have
have I I go there mostly every day side
beans
break-ins you get free chips don't you
pay for the chips salsa bar it's a deal
sweet Slade a dime all under the weather
today I can't deal with Jordan I'm sorry
I also don't want Conan coming in
because I don't want to get him sick I'm
sick or he'd like to say that it's
Michael Williams I'll tell accounting
you said you loved him thank you that's
interesting we hit them when you hit the
border of the thing it's like pulls you
back in but it's so it's kind of cool
it's like not in a way that there's like
a wall it kind of pulls you back in
which is going the goal of this game the
point a is to chill out and enjoy life
some things we're exploring but we're
trying to find right now you need like a
kid this camera thing oh you know what I
think is up here you need you're going
through different portals in the game
let's you activate Oh someone said I
notice he has no issue getting best sick
Beth can't be sick she's a synth sorry
that's why she's so good at computers
Beth is one of the person who gets us
sick yeah I just release in the talks
yeah someone is asking how long do we do
doing this almost two years right two
years ma'am that's great thank you you
think we'd be better at it
thank you for joining us on this that's
right when is the anniversary by the way
we should have a big first was it really
we sent it to your anniversary party
next Monday we're offered oh wait we're
off we are off we're off next week this
is the party right now that will do what
we come back I mean we won't because
it'll be exhausted we will have one soon
we'll make up an anniversary yeah where
does anyone see the camera around here
guys I'm looking for a shark that ate my
camera anyone anyone anyone know the
whereabouts of that do we have a
favorite Conan Remote
automatically like the old time I'll
tell me baseball remotes real fun yeah I
love me obviously other clues camera
three
I like American Girl doll storyline
student driver remote was fun oh yeah
those are classic maybe I should go in
the dark hole guys should I go into the
dark hole why am I asking the internet
that got me question it's not gonna let
me in i don't think i get into the dark
hole oh I can oh I should have been
going here the whole time
oh there it is there's our camera
wait Gene Wilder just died that can't be
true extremely sad
he was on late night actually it's
really cool super crazy funny land work
dude
alright let's go open up the weird web
door we tarnished let's get the
relationship therapist is good whose
subnautica
is a survival giving the ocean maybe now
we only play ocean game so here we go
we're back in this is like the subway
this is like the ocean subway
[Music]
what about if I grabbed on the one who
can I grab on to Liddy's fish
[Music]
I'm supposed to be hitting these big
fish
[Music]
this gorgeous man what a pretty game
[Music]
I don't know what it does what I'm
hitting these fish but I like it look
look I do his kelp oh geez
what were those whoa orcas guys and I
ride on an orca oh this is joke this
game is insanely beautiful this is
probably what the oceans were like
before humans came along
[Music]
this is crazy what's going on also like
I love like look how big everything is
I'm so small now
whoa did you trick what horrid SeaWorld
now it's terrible
East Burt that can't be right
what's the BSL group of orcas a pod I
think you're right oh you know if
everything is a group of crows is called
a murder of crows yeah and a pride of
lions is Kate like a murder flock of
seagulls also a great band never poop my
pants no I never have thank you for your
mature question what is this
was comic-con as crazy as it looked
hopefully it looked really put together
not crazy
should we go down can we go down there
we go to the portal
yeah me too Astros fan this game makes
me wish I was a merman Astros here's the
thing all right Murr me Ivan I have
something to say I have a point everyone
is all about Lego mermaids are so hot
they're so hot right and they're like
you know half naked woman half fish
that's funny no one ever talks about the
other side of that which is the main
verse okay
the made Murr is a is a is a creature
from the ocean that I just made up now
wait I'm the opposite of a mermaid which
is the top half of the woman is a fish
and the bottom half is female not as
attractive huh but they you know what
they're creatures in the ocean - that's
right you know what where's the love for
the maid Murs you know they're people -
well half people so everyone's in love
with the mermaid oh I love mermaids I
love mer
well you know what made MERS are cool -
okay so let's give a little love to them
tired of you guys not talking about
Maiden verse little mermaid right that
was a Disney movie I didn't see the
little maid mer Pixar's not people
aren't lining up to make that film poor
maid Murs I'm sorry maid Marie if
they're a maid where's watching I
apologize on behalf of my species and we
haven't quite figured out what species
that is yet so we had question would
Connor never do a podcast we have a
podcast we just started it like a month
ago that's right we restarted the team
Pogo podcast Conan has done Conan has
done a couple of them the pod yeah he's
done a couple he did the team cocoa
podcast he did the late-night podcast
back in the day this jelly thing isn't
working for some reason um you know what
because I gotta go to this thing come
here
all right side a couple of them and yes
he will do the podcast at some point he
does love talking well people do talk
about that Casey way see bear family I
did a joke about it yeah they did a joke
about it exactly that's my point
everyone's joking about it Oh made
Merson neighbors know their people have
people - it's not a joking matter okay
here we go let's put our globe of our
body inside this weird blob
release the Orcas oh you know what
something very like Lisa Frank about
this there's a very Lisa Frank about
that I'm sure you know what we saw wait
a second remember we saw on the thing
that or that whales were one of the on
the weird panels so this is like the
third level basically the the last one
was manta rays and now this one is
working or killer whales we wanna be
like yes thank you Robert veg I am
that's right I'm trying to bring bring
awareness to it
I think that's near and dear to my heart
now here here's the problem last time
again beautiful game for following the
way the last time we remember a shark
came and like [ __ ] our [ __ ] up man
look at this game you guys this is crazy
beautiful you know one thing I will say
about the ocean that has going for it no
sense of smell
you know yeah like kelp smells terrible
if you like anything that washes up on
the beach fish smell terrible
it's gross but I rate the water you
can't smell anything that's awesome what
a place to be alive it's a kelp house
uh-oh shark is bad but wait a second
let's look at this it's like the shark
is a globe or something
there there god oh wait let's look at
this part over here it'd be hard to
build stuff underwater like how do you
get all this stuff this beats cemented
together there's a whale all right
there's the same thing does that means
something all of a sudden you just start
seeing skeletons everywhere whoa look at
this holy crap
swordfish
[Music]
whoo that's fine Wow
this is so cool this actually is
legitimately awesome this is crazy
bring ocean is in this game exactly we
are in the frankish this is the new
Frank Ocean video
this is like high school trying to get
to class
excuse me excuse me sorry look at this
whoo this is fun it is this game is
pretty dope definitely worth of I'll say
that oh oh look at this dude I'm scared
yeah we can meditate should we met it's
a real quick
[Music]
I don't need a meditate that's what the
thing all right let's go I want to go
down and see if we can talk to this
whale I'm nervous though man something
that's big
the will just run into that rock I think
the well just ran into that rock that's
a good
[Music]
well riding dudes in fact well I think
it's like $900 way to be including the
ex pot that ps4 we're playing out do buy
new when you say you buy game right
exactly
dude David David Attenborough
that should be DLC whoa all right we're
gonna swim down and see if we can find I
hate going to the bottom this is the
worst okay okay guys get your hump back
puns Oh Oh God oh my God look how far
down we can go this is crazy
yeah look at how big this game is Jesus
oh my god what is down here ruins
you know what I don't want to run into
of those weird fish with the lanterns on
their faces and the huge crazy teeth
and you can buy it on Steam for PC - why
am i releasing sharks all the coolest
see Emily yeah that's true you're right
here you go also sleeping horse from
before the dawn of time yeah little
Cthulhu
Cthulhu
look at these weird ruins
is this no man's sky but in water no to
King Dismas this is way better than no
man's sky this gave me so an unrealistic
no oxygen yeah I like that though I was
saying earlier like it's really
frustrating like I like swimming around
in games but they never give you enough
oxygen like to really do anything hey by
the way no man's sky included yeah so
this game is very its this game is very
satisfying and we'll say that
let's go up whoa look at that I think
he's eating
I think the whale is like eating
plankton or something that's crazy oh no
this is a whale shark I think we ride
this thing
yeah we can ride them
well basking shark that's what it is
yeah they don't eat they just eat
plankton
it's like flashlight batteries yeah
thank you try this flashlight batteries
every game that lasts for two minutes
max it's ridiculous it's not a way look
at the tail you're right
thank you very smart Thomas
dad David Alondra we got a little mer
man situation happening
blow might noses arena it's not really a
blowing nose situation there's nothing
in there and just have the sniffles
alright let's go up to the giant weird
thing so is this whole look it's in like
like is it in like huge spaceship or
something
look what is up with thee I'm saying
yeah like the portal isn't a giant thing
of rocks are we going inside this rock
thing who built this stuff I want to
know
I would seriously use this game to teach
my students about sea animals yeah you
should it's great let's go now it's
orange I'm nervous
they don't eat meat but stick your head
in its mouth and see what happens what
is the Harambee thing he's a gorilla
it's like gorillas that hurrying that
child so big oh that was Harambee all
right I don't know whatever blue to it
this game is less like every blue - more
like Blue Crush which is a movie about a
bunch of female surfers I've seen oh
we've all seen it actually I've never
seen Kate Bosworth what happens Kate
Bosworth has two different color eyes
only that's part of the plan I was just
like in real life
yeah really like Bowie Bowie style yeah
yeah and she I think I'm getting
confused with like the Disney movie
where the girl whoa oh oh this
definitely looks real bad
[Music]
it's autumn here in the the ocean here
there's a giant change through this
this game could use more puzzles I'll
say that but maybe that's what this is
going to be
[Music]
but that a whole shark
this is one trippy game guys look
there's a civilization here before us
wait there's another we didn't come
through me he didn't come with me on the
other who's leaving all these here by
the way for us how many hours of sleep
do you typically get asked Connor I try
to get eight good what I normally get a
six except these chains oh and look at
this it's like a crocodile got like so
back oh the Egyptian crocodile god I
mean you got this looks like an eel God
actually this looks like a this you know
this looks like an eel business man
getting ready to go to work with his pot
of coffee
oh yeah yeah just like mmm coffee in the
morning yeah before I guess it's Prius
yeah
[Music]
whoa look at this this is crazy man they
did a good job making this game oh
really beautiful oh and here's his pal
office me hammerhead guy hey Bill what's
up how was your weekend pretty good this
is a little fish yeah this is this game
is gorgeous
[Music]
just a bunch of happy fish what is this
kind of fish hold on wait I'm gonna see
what kind of fish is this yeah like yeah
like swim sideways what is this thing
call what tell us we write a sunfish
there we go like swim sideways scalloped
hammerhead there we go that's released a
bunch of dangerous sharks that's a good
idea
oh this guy's like broken or something
there's a team go go to Netherlands
hashtag happening have equal
oh we just have a new one now
haha from all this you know somebody had
a happy little accident yeah exactly
I have two of these little cameras now
we got man we got manatees yeah
[Music]
well guys we're almost done for today's
questions in let me see what's behind
this door
nope can't go through there oh we your
guy look like color now oh yeah cos
orange
we got to do something with these chains
you know what when we release one is
hammerhead and one is eel so we released
the hammerhead
I bet and the chains will disappear
never release the eel and the chains
will disappear so here we go we gotta go
down over here
[Music]
go go gadget chains right then we go to
go back up so is this all not under
water at some point is that the idea
baby
it's been flooded or it's always been
underwater how do you build
infrastructure I don't know I was
thinking about that
there's so many fish down here what do
they all eat
I guess each other unfortunately guys
that's that's how life works you know
circle life
this is cool oh wait that's go down over
here maybe soccer man the thing about
this game is it's about exploration like
journey look at not every game has to be
Call of Duty and I like that not every
game is Call of Duty and I like the fact
that these guys so you know one of my
favorite games all the a fall of all
time is Connemara Damacy because it's
different and cool and strange you don't
know what's gonna happen
that's what's cool at this game do you
have no idea what's going on and that's
in the beginning and kind of as you
figure it out you know it's beautiful
and it's more of an experience us here
we go it's more of an experience than it
is about like points or leaderboards or
whatever and that way I like it it's and
it's kind of like you know it's all like
movies are all different and games are
all different I think that's cool
and it's a game that takes its time
there's nothing wrong with that
a lot of times those games like again
like inside our games that can be the
most rewarding
[Music]
and whoever was down there before closed
the door like enable and then just leave
it open man what's your problem
[Music]
see you Shady
[Music]
let's see what's over here Beth what's
your opinion on sharks being able to
smell blood underwater for miles
I would like to pivot visit to a
stranger sings conversation you seen
stranger things I haven't seen the whole
thing yet everything the whole thing yet
oh yeah that I almost finished it I
watched it for so good seven hours but I
haven't finished it that's a lot of
hours sand
oh man we're not gonna figure out this
puzzle before the end of the stream damn
it no stranger oh now there's gonna be
serious things spoilers well that's ok
you know what we're gonna end this
stream I don't gotta go do it don't ruin
it for us please guys that's gonna do it
for today we're an industry we know what
I see stranger things spoilers you guys
are dicks
the game is abs you it's absolutely it's
absolutely awesome thank you and we'll
see you guys in two weeks
cuz we're off next week and go get this
game it's beautiful especially if you're
having some stress in your life it will
make you there meditation is in the game
it's pretty great thank you for joining
us Chicago Beth Morosky Jason O'Malley
I've got a cold alright see you guys in
two week see you later bye
[Music]
you